welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Bossa and Thor love and thunder released
new TV spots and footage teasing some
interesting new clues about this movie's
villain villain or the god Butcher and
what exactly Thor is doing with the
Guardians of the Galaxy other than you
know I guess trying to bang them all
despite this film impressively still
keeping much of the story Under Wraps
we've actually learned some major
details this week that we've got to
break down and a reminder that the best
way to support new rock stars is to
check out our new Miss Marvel inspired
shirt Cosmic Daydream over at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay let's take a
look at the latest tickets on sale promo
how are we doing I would love to show
you this in full but I guess YouTube
decided that if we play Axel Rose's
voice longer than three seconds I gotta
mow everyone's yards for a month so
let's just take it bit by bit the First
new shot shows Thor's arrival to the
battle alongside the Guardians of the
Galaxy on the planet that I think is
Centauri for how we doing guys Drax
responds we're all about to die and then
Rocket jumps in who said this would be a
relaxing holiday
I said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday you'll notice Thor is
wearing this Poncho and has his hair
tied back in a bun the same look and
loungewear that he's rocking when he's
meditating under that Wisdom Tree the
latest full trailer added two figures
walking up to him presumably to the
Guardians begging him to come help out
with this battle and then the shot of
him dramatically unfurly in his Poncho
to reveal his big trouble little China
outfit underneath with a vest made out
of Peter Quill's jacket I think the gag
there is really the fact that he had
this on underneath the Poncho the whole
time or the guy is just capable of
magical wardrobe quick changes which is
a big detail about the character from
the comics when he had the alter ego of
Dr Donald Blake and would tap his
umbrella to turn into mjolnir a little
goofy Authority until that the MCU films
haven't really explored that much and
the fact that the flashback shows them
back in his yellow boots I think they're
going to be touched back on a lot of
that stuff in love and thunder so then
later when Zeus flicks off his robes I
think the expectation there is that once
again Thor might just have on a
different outfit underneath the disguise
but since the Olympians have de-powered
him he's just bare ass naked underneath
which then raises the question why
exactly are all all those Olympians
fainting like what is it about his you
know a Stormbreaker down there is it
just like two
two small is it a weird shape is it too
bright is it like inside out is it tied
in a bow is it tied in like a Norse
Asgardian braid is the hair braided like
that don't get mad at me for asking
these questions they put it in the movie
anyway Rocket says Thor promised them a
relaxing holiday so they're not
necessarily on this planet intentionally
to save the zatoan tribe the conflict
really just sprung up while they were
there trying to relax and they also just
view that for Thor war-torn regions are
just his happy place it seems like in
the First Act of this film Thor will
have used the Guardians and really a
one-sided relationship to get back into
shade back in the rhythm of his life and
now with another classic thou Adventure
but one that might leave him feeling
still unfulfilled but I love the framing
and the movement of Rocket we do not see
his legs he's just kind of like Bobs
across the screen the way a muppet just
kind of bounces now the VFX on Rocket
has always been pretty great in these
films but part of the reason why is that
they have a practical stand in fur
puppet version of the character when
they shoot this stuff and if in this
movie taikwaditi Embraces more of the
puppetry that could be another way we
get more practical laughs from the
character like the puppeteering works
really well for growth in the
Mandalorian shows and since this is the
first time we've seen rocket in the
movie since grogu has entered Our Lives
I just wouldn't blame them for trying to
go more practical in some of these shots
I like how the zatoan chieftain has a
plastic cone around his neck who knows
if this is part of his ceremonial guard
or if he had like an injury of some kind
but in this section he likely caught
this image of Valkyrie licking her sword
which do not do that your tongue's right
next to the blade you can cut it but the
blood that she's licking off is
splattered on her arms her fist her
forearm her armor and yeah it is golden
in fact that sword as we see in another
shot is green colored the gold on the
blade is their blood The Olympian guards
there fighting in a scene have golden
armor golden flesh and probably bleed
the color gold and this may remind you
of The Sovereign and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 and that may be by Design
the Warriors supplied Olympus may be
provided by The Sovereign the same breed
of genetic super soldiers that Adam
Warlock is Will Poulter will play Adam
Warlock in Guardians volume 3. and I'm
interested to see if in this film either
with a line or a cameo or something in
the post-credits scene Mike catches up
with Aisha's Vengeance plot against the
Guardians via Adam in that cocoon but
there's another new clip in this trailer
times like this we need to come together
quite a reunion huh yeah it sounds like
Thor will join this new Asgard town hall
meeting after the attack on the town
from the black Berserkers and showing up
Valkyrie a little bit who now rules over
this Kingdom this may be the political
turmoil a new Asgard it was teased by
the Spider-Man no way home news ticker
and we also just saw an Easter egg in
Miss Marvel episode 1 that as far as New
Jersey they are handing out pamphlets
for tours of new Asgard so the colony's
new status is a tourist destination
might be inviting some unwelcome
attention for some refugees who just
wanted a quiet peaceful existence after
the events of Ragnarok and thanks to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week so you can Savor summer
flavors right from home get in a
home-cooked meal on the table every day
is an accomplishment worth celebrating
hellofresh now has 30 dinner recipes to
choose from every week that is the most
Choice options of any meal kid out there
so you can think less about what's for
dinner and more about what Tony Stark
does when he needs to sneeze inside the
Iron Man suit I mean think about it's
it's going to make a mess or is there
like a filter does it recycle it like
the rest of its fluids anyway I like how
easy it is to make these recipes
foolproof step-by-step recipes mean a
joyful cooking experience in a
stress-free summer plus hellofresh Cuts
back on the time spent in the kitchen
with meals ready in around 30 minutes or
less it's also a great value even at
full price it's pre-portioned
ingredients mean you don't have to waste
money on excess food save those dollars
for your cosplay budget hellofresh is up
to 72 percent cheaper than dying at a
restaurant or grocery shopping I
recently made some delicious
mouth-watering burgers
oh
not for you that's made my mouth feel so
well taken care of I talk like this now
go to hellofresh.com and use the code
rockstars16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts Jane says quite a
reunion huh and we actually learned this
week from interviews with the cast in
d23 magazine via the director this film
will feature flashbacks to Thor and
Jane's past relationship including their
breakup and those might be the funniest
moments in the entire film Chris
Hemsworth said whoa there actually
wasn't a whole lot of evidence to
definitively say this is how they broke
up this is what happened it was left
open for an interpretation which was
great because it allowed us to go on
this fun Journey what did their
relationship looked like when they were
together wanted to look like when they
were breaking up why did they break up
it's some of the funniest stuff in the
film Natalie Portman added it was really
fun to get to imagine the parts of the
relationship we hadn't seen and the hard
parts of a scientist dating an unworldly
superhero and again I'm just gonna say
what caused all those Olympians debate
might be the reason they broke up it's
just too much to manage too much too
much oh the Places my mind goes another
promo included one new line from Gore
the God but true
better without guns I like how he says
the world will be better without Gods
when we are in a galaxy filled with
multiple worlds what planet is he
referring to Earth his home planet
either way it's just interesting that he
stays singular there and one thing I
love about all the footage of Gore so
far is that it seems to show a physical
transition throughout the film for this
character it looks as though he begins
his film as stringy but strong yet big
into killer but in the shots of what I
assume is a film's climax he now has
scarring and open wounds bleeding into
his robes high contrast thick Shadow
lighting and monochrome evoking the
German expressionist style from the
1920s and films like the cabinet of Dr
Caligari and it's now making a bit of a
comeback in movies like the tragedy of
Macbeth it just seems like Gore is
coming into this movie with nothing to
lose and erodes into an increasingly
monstrous form uncaring if he makes it
out of this a lie in that same d23
magazine piece Hemsworth called
Christian Bale's performance quote
brilliant saying quote the rest of us
would be in our world of improvisation
comedy and fun then he'd walk on set we
don't look at each other and say oh my
God this is really intense this is
really scary and Tessa Thompson said
quote bail towed this really great line
because he needs to be terrifying but
also needs to work in the context of our
colorful Snappy irreverent world and I
think it's so telling that she used the
word colorful as a point of contrast
because the footage shows her fighting
Gore with Zeus's lightning bolt as Gore
appears to be draining the Technicolor
from her body so visually Gore is a
monochromatic character in a vibrant
rainbow setting of these Thor movies and
as this movie progresses it looks like
it's going to transform all the
photography into black and white in
general a sign of great visual
storytelling is whether you can watch a
movie and still understand it without
the dialogue and it looks like
taikwatiti is aiming for that here I
cannot wait to see the color palette
breakdown of all the frames this movie
zoomed out and how it becomes a spectrum
of color dreaming into gray tone tickets
going on sale Monday so brace yourselves
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos followed Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]